-Guys, finally, it is Tuesday,
it is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you
five different tweets.
We're all gonna vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
I can see everyone scrambling,
yeah.
Some of you have 'em,
some of 'em don't.
Okay, well, look.
Borrow your friend's.
You can all vote for -- You can
vote for all of them, okay?
Or you can vote for
none of them.
Whatever you want to do.
I want you to have fun.
You're here.
I'm happy you're here.
We're gonna see the results
live.
Higgins, Roots,
you guys have clickers?
-Got it, got it.
-Very good.
Whatever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out live
on the show so that you can all
like it and "wetweet" it.
[ Audience groans ]
Yeah. It's a shared experience.
There's no groan --
There's no "groan" button on
these, are there?
-Is there?
-Alright, here we go.
Ready to do this?
[ Cheers ]
Alright.
The first tweet is...
[ Light laughter ]
I dunno, the band even came in
late on that one.
Yeah. Alright.
I don't think
anyone liked that one.
[ Laughter ]
Are the votes -- The votes are
close, I can already tell.
Let's see the results,
let's see who voted for it.
Ooh. My goodness.
[ Sad tuba plays ]
-Wow.
-"Hey, my eyes are up here,
bud."
[ Laughter ]
That's alright.
We have four more chances.
-Yeah.
-This next one is...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, not too bad.
-Not bad.
-That's dece.
-It's dece?
-Dece?
-Yeah, that's decent.
I'm gonna say -- I haven't put
my vote in yet.
-I'm gonna say 80.
-I'm not --
I'm gonna vote no on it.
-You're gonna vote no?
-Yeah.
-Alright, let's see it.
-Why would I vote no?
I gotta be honest.
-Yeah.
-I gotta be real.
Gotta be truthful.
-Yeah.
-And that's the way I feel.
-Wow.
-I feel like other ones --
Something else will be the one.
It's not this one.
I think it's funny.
-Right. Clever.
-There's no reason that
the 5-pound weights
should be smaller.
-Right.
-They're all the same size.
Oh, I guess --
-They are different sizes.
[ Laughter ]
-Size doesn't matter, Jimmy.
-Yeah.
-You've been telling me that
for years.
I've been saying that for years!
-Finally, thank you.
I've been saying that for --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's see the results here.
I say 50/50.
Oh, not bad. Alright, good.
That's good.
We got some positivity in
the audience, I love that.
Alright. Here we go.
This next one is...
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good one!
-"Where -- Hello?"
-"Uh, where are we?"
[ Laughter ]
I like this one.
This one seems promising to me.
Last one was 135. It's a very
happy, positive audience.
I'm going to say it's up
in the 170 range.
-70s?
-I agree. I agree.
-Okay.
-Tariq agrees.
Let's see the results.
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
190!
That's a hit!
-Snap.
-That's a hit right there.
-193.
-"Uh, where are we?"
-My godness.
-Yeah. Here, check out this next
one here. It said...
[ Laughter ]
-That's a good one too.
-It's a good one. It's long.
-Yeah.
-But it's good.
'Cause when one of that thing
goes off, you're like, "Ohh!"
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
Let's see the results on this.
-Ohh.
-That's good!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're down to our last one.
-Last is good.
-But I don't think you're gonna
top the bowling ball one.
-No.
-But this one might do it.
-The bowling ball one's quirky.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, aren't we all?
-Yeah, why not?
-I think this one is just
kind of a solid...
-B, C?
-No, this is a solid A.
This is a good one.
-Really?
-This one could win
the whole thing.
I hope that the bowling ball one
wins.
-Right, but this one might.
This one might take the cake.
-I feel like it might.
-Okay, let's hear it.
-I dunno.
[ Laughter ]
-That's smart.
-I -- Yeah, but I --
Don't get me -- It's a thinker.
It's a bit of a thinker.
-You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah.
-But bowling ball wasn't
a thinker?
-Nah, bowling ball was the jam.
-That was a jam?
-Yeah, bowling ball was
the G.O.A.T. of today.
-Alright, let's see.
What do you guys think?
Let's see the results.
There's your answer right there.
It is bowling ball.
It is "where are we?"
I'm gonna post this
during the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like, give it
a "wetweet," enjoy!